こんにちは、はじめしゃちょ...
あっ
おはようございます。はじめしゃちょーです。
只今！朝の十時半でございます。
おはようと言いたいとこなんだが、
僕は、今から寝ます。
約2ヶ月分の洗濯物を洗濯してて、
ようやく今から寝ることになります...
俺はね、寝起きに関しては多分、あの、本当にマジで、
多分、日本、の、100、位、以内に入ってるぐらい寝起きがいい方だと思ってるので、
ちょっと起きた瞬間のね、脳の回転力がめちゃくちゃ早いんすよ。
即覚醒。思考判断力が即MAXまで上がる。
もう、多分、起きた瞬間でも世界が滅びるか滅ばないかの決断を迫られてても
瞬時に答えれることができると思うんですよ僕は。
それぐらい多分ね、寝起きには僕自信あります。
いや、マジでね！
寝起きに関しては、俺の隣に出るものはいないと思っているで。
僕のこの寝起きのインテリジェンスィーをねえ、もっと皆さんに見せつけるために、
こちらの時計のアプリがあるんですけども、これがねえ、アラーム設定できて、
「はーい、はじめちゃん、おきましょうね～、あさでちゅよぉ～」
(アラームアプリ)「はーい、はじめちゃん、おきましょうね～、あさでちゅよぉ～」
ぶっ
自分でね、アラームの声が決められます。
要するに起きるとき音を自分で決めれるので
今回！私が思ったのは、この音を僕の声にします。
で、どんな声にするかといいますと、そうだな...
計算にしよう
今から寝るんですけども、寝起きでかける、僕を今から起こすアラームの音を計算にします。
寝てる時のアラームが計算になるわけですよ。
計算式が言われて、3+4は?とか言われた瞬間僕は、
「7」
って、起きます。
もう寝ながら計算をするぐらいの勢いですから。
いや、多分、多分ね、1発目でいけると思うんですよ
寝起きで計算させられると、何回目で、バシッと、瞬間的に答えれるか
って言うちょと検証をして見ようと思います。
では！
おやすみなさい。
「(アラームアプリ)4+7は？」
「(アラームアプリ)8-3は？」
「(アラームアプリ)4+nan...8-sa...」
これで2つ設定したので、今から寝ます。
そして答える！
(出題音)
「(アラームアプリ)4+7は？」
ﾊｧｰｯｱｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯ(途中ｯﾌﾞｯﾌﾞｰ)ﾊｱｱｯｱｧｱｱ
じゅうい・・・！
(出題音)
「(アラームアプリ)8-3は？」
あぁぁぁ
うぇー？
8-sssssssssssss
11！
(不正解音)
「(アラームアプリ)8-3は？」
あうぇ?
...11
(不正解音)
(LINE着信音)
あ、あっあっあうぇうぇうぇうぇうぇあっあっうぇ
あ?
(LINE着信音)
撮影中だよ...
(出題音)
「(アラームアプリ)8-3は？」
5！！！
うぉ？あれ？あれ？あ…
「(アラームアプリ)8-3は？」
5だって
あー…、言えました
「(アラームアプリ)8-3は？」
もう覚えちゃったよ